E aí
oi oi eu estou aqui hoje para contar
para vocês a minha história contar para
vocês como foi que eu consegui
transformar aqueles que seriam os piores
momentos da minha vida nos momentos mais
incríveis
e eu te faço uma pergunta você já
desistiu da sua vida já achou que o seu
sofrimento não tinha mais solução vem
comigo nessa jornada e vamos passear
juntos pelos momentos mais incríveis e
mais inesquecíveis da minha vida
e essa jornada ela começa lá atrás ela
começa com a minha mãe a minha mãe ainda
grávida já no final da gestação o médico
chega para ela e fala assim mãezinha a
sua filha é muito forte mas ela tem um
tumor
e ela não vai alcançar os seis meses
depois que ela nascer
e naquele momento eu recebi a minha
primeira sentença
o que aquele médico ele estava certo
e aos seis meses de vida eu passei pela
minha primeira cirurgia
o e ao final dela depois de um tempo
mais uma vez aquele médico ele chega
para minha mãe e fala mãezinha
e a sua filha é muito forte
é mas ela não vai chegar no sete anos é
o máximo o tumor ainda está aí
e naquele momento a minha segunda
sentença e também iniciou uma infância
muito restrita
e sempre entrando e saindo dos hospitais
as dores elas eram sempre constantes e
eu me lembro que na maioria das vezes eu
ficava sentada na arquibancada vendo
meus amigos brincarem E se divertirem eu
não podia eu não podia correr
o e sete anos se passaram e aquele
médico ele estava certo
E mais uma vez
e eu me lembro que sentada esperando a
minha vez de ser atendida com meu pai
ali do meu lado
eu olhei para ele e vi aquele sofrimento
estampado no rosto
e a dor o cansaço
E qual é o filho que não quer ver o pai
bem não é verdade e eu queria ver o meu
pai muito bem e muito feliz então olhei
para ele e falei assim pai foi embora
E aí vamos para casa aí vamos largar
isso para lá vamos vamos para casa aí
ele
e vamos mas olha minha filha se você
fizer esse exame acordada nós vamos mais
rápido nós podemos ir para casa mais
rápido ainda
e eu pensei pai vai doer tanto pai e eu
vou chorar era muito doloroso
É mas ele disse para mim
se você consegue
E ai a gente pode ir para casa eu falei
tá bom vamos embora eu consigo eu
consigo eu consigo E aí eu fui
e eles me chamaram e logo no caminho
caminhando para a sala né onde eu ia
fazer o exame eu reparei que os
corredores eles eram brancos
e já na sala me preparando fazendo toda
aquela preparação
eu reparei também que as luzes as roupas
dos médicos os móveis tudo era branco
e na minha mão segurava alquimen naquela
época Walkman amarelo amarelo porque
amarelo e me lembrava o sol e eu adoro
sol e quando eu coloquei ele todo
Amarelo ali em cima daquela mesa branca
eu reparei que ele ele se destacou
e nem eu pensei
e esse aumentasse essas paredes de
amarelo
bom E se eu pintasse as luzes de Rosa os
médicos de azul será que vai ficar mais
legal mais interessante e foi assim que
eu fiz um
hoje eu trouxe o sol para dentro daquele
quarto e coloquei um arco-íris lá dentro
Ah e quando eu menos esperava já tinha
acabado o exame já tinha acabado e eu
não tenho sentido a dor
e foi tudo rápido
e depois daquele dia mas sete anos se
passaram
e sempre naquela restrição
é mas muito bem graças a Deus E mais uma
vez aquele médico ele chega para minha
mãe e diz mãezinha sua filha é muito
forte
É mas o tumor Ele ainda tá aí
e ele cresceu ele está muito grande ele
atingir outros órgãos e já não há nada
que nós possamos fazer nós vamos ter que
operar ela novamente
eu e Alice iniciou a minha segunda
jornada
há poucos dias depois lá estava eu no
internada novamente e dali eu fiz a
minha segunda a minha terceira a minha
quarta cirurgia
a e na quarta cirurgia eu desistir
é porque o sofrimento ele cansa
e a dor eu também cansa
Aí eu desisti olhei para minha mãe
sentada ali do meu lado naquela
cadeirinha de Boteco sei se vocês já
viram né a cadeira de plástico me
pergunto hoje como foi que ela ficou
tanto tempo naquela cadeira dormindo
e lá estava ela e eu perguntei Mãe
É deixa eu ir mãe
tu já olhou para mim falou assim deixa
mas você me leva com você
e eu falei não Mãe você tem que ficar
você precisa ficar
e ela mais sem você eu não vou ficar
eu me lembro com você mas eu já tava
cansada
e para mim já tinha dado
eu não queria mais
Aí eu desisti
e naquele momento existir alguns dias
depois eu entrei em coma
bom e algumas semanas depois eu acordei
quando eu acordei eu já não comia mais
parei de comer parei de beber parei de
andar parei de falar e minha mãe ela
vendo que eu aos poucos estava me
despedindo né dela e de todos ela fez
algo surpreendente
se você já foi desafiado
e eu fui desafiada pela minha mãe
e ela pegou um cartaz enorme muito
grande e colocou na parte mais distante
do meu quarto na parede mais longe
e eu não conseguia ver o que que tava
ali quando acordei de vida aconteceu eu
falei
e eu conversei mãe que aquilo
oi e ela não sei da cadeirinha de botar
que ela olhou para mim não sei vai lá
vai lá e olha
e eu falei mãe mais como como que eu vou
lá eu uso fralda
e eu não sei andar
e se vira
Ah tá bom nos dias que se passaram eu
voltei a me alimentar
eu voltei a conversar sentei tirei a
fralda sentei na cadeira de rodas e lá
vai eu na cadeira de rodas e fui até a
parede me lembro da mensagem que eu ligo
e tava escrito lá daquele cartaz enorme
estou na arquibancada da vida torcendo
por você
é aquela hora eu falei não não é mais o
porquê mas sim por quem por quem eu
estou aqui e olhei para minha mãe de
novo naquela cadeirinha e falei ah por
você e eu vou
eu voltei a andar aprendido a andar
novamente
bom e depois daquele dia eu passei a
frequentar diariamente a brinquedoteca
brinquedoteca era a salinha da Oncologia
pediátrica onde eu me encontrava com os
meus amiguinhos os amiguinhos os
coleguinhas que passaram pela mesma
situação que eu
e eu me lembrei daquele dia lá atrás com
sete anos que eu colori aquele quarto e
eu falei vou dar um pincel para cada um
eu ensinei cada um deles a colorir
o e aprende com eles também porque nós
não não éramos mais pacientes nós éramos
príncipes' eram as princesas guerreiros
Ninjas não era o hospital era um castelo
era uma floresta e nós lutávamos contra
tudo contra todos contra toda dor era
incrível
O incrível é que nós compartilhávamos os
nossos momentos os nossos sonhos nossos
desejos o que você vai fazer
e quando isso acabar
e qual o seu sonho nos compartilhávamos
Ah e não importava qual era o próximo
passo e o quão doloroso ele seria não
importava a quimioterapia radioterapia
endoscopia não importava
Eu adorei era pequena porque nós
sabíamos que podíamos compartilhar e com
outro compartilhe sempre sempre eram que
nós fazemos
a todos os dias e aquele médico ele mais
uma vez chegou para minha mãe mãezinha
Sua filha melhorou
Eu estou muito bem
e naquela para casa
e pode levar ela para casa
e eu me arrumei vestir a minha calça
jeans
é toda linda ah Pensa numa pessoa feliz
minha mãe que ela deu um pulo da cadeira
de Boteco que vocês não acreditam e ela
veio me abraçou e nós vamos embora vamos
embora e vamos para casa
e eu prometi quando eu saí dali porque
eu tava realizando meu sonho sabe qual
era o meu sonho você faz ideia de qual
era o meu sonho era ver o sol era sentir
tocar na minha pele já tinha mais de
oito meses que eu não sabia que era isso
e quando eu saí lá fora com a minha
calça jeans que ele tocou a minha pele
eu falei assim eu vou aproveitar cada
minuto cada momento da minha vida cada
segundo
e eu voltei para casa da minha família
para os meus irmãos
é mais uma semana depois
e lá estava eu voltando
tá piorando de novo
o e naquela volta enquanto eu e a minha
mãe estávamos indo de novo para o
hospital minha mãe chegou para mim e
falou assim aí é isso que a gente
precisa passar ali nós precisamos nos
despedir de alguém
e eu falei quem mãe ela não é muito
rápido
Oi e aí Nós entramos em uma igreja
a filha da porta da igreja eu vivo ainda
lá no fundo bem lá o lado do altar a
imagem de uma das minhas amiguinhas
e brincava comigo da brinquedoteca
Daiane era a imagem dela
a minha mãe virou para mim falou assim
minha filha ela desistiu e eu me
lembrava naquele momento dela falando
comigo aí esca não desiste se você
desistir com a boa daí ele sempre falava
isso comigo
e naquele momento eu parei e silêncio eu
me despedir dela da minha amiga e
prometi para ela eu não vou desistir
e no outro dia lá estava eu de novo no
hospital com mãe enquanto ela tava
fazendo aquela parte burocrática
eu resolvi Nas questões do hospital
Olá eu sou de correr sair correndo pelos
corredores e eu escutei uma voz para voz
de um dos meus amiguinhos João Marcos eu
escutei a voz dele aí eu saí correndo eu
falei cadê João cadê João e vi a mãe
dele parada na porta de um quarto
eu cheguei para ele e falei tinha hein
Oi cadê João e ela está ali olha lá ele
não é João como você tá não tinha 4 anos
a aliança e Mia já tinha atingido ele
muito forte e aí João eu voltei para
casa João eu tô em casa e ela virou para
mim falar isso que nós também estamos
esperando uma vaga na Pediatria para
gente subir e eu tinha eu vou subir
também a gente se encontra lá em cima se
encontra João e ele se encontra a gente
vai se ver lá para encantar voltei para
minha mãe
há algumas semanas depois eu subi com
ela para Pediatria avisar mais uma
cirurgia outra cirurgia e assim que eu
conseguir andar de novo a primeira coisa
que eu fiz sair correndo pelos
corredores procurando encontrei tia Isa
é uma enfermeira
o que já cuidava da gente
a irmã falei tia Isa cadê João tia
oi e ela ajoelhou e virou para mim falou
assim oh minha princesa João não subiu
o João deu a vaga dele para você para
que você subisse
e eu falei tia cadê a Ana Júlia Ana
Júlia se despediu de nós uma semana
depois que você saiu assim como o Marcos
e o Vinícius
e eu voltei para o quarto voltei para
minha mãe olhei para ela de novo naquela
academia de Boteco E mais uma vez na
vida deixou de fazer sentido para mim
E mais uma vez eu quis desistir
é mas aí eu escutei de novo a voz de
Dayane no meu ouvido
e não desiste aí as que não desiste
nunca olhei para minha mãe e falei não é
porque mas por quem
e eu falei eu vou levantar de novo eu
vou sair daqui
E aí de novo percorre os hospitais eu
percorri aqueles corredores e eu saí de
novo e fiz novos amiguinhos e peguei meu
pincel entreguei para ele se nós todos
voltamos a colorir
e príncipes princesas guerras tudo nosso
enfrentavam o estudo enfrentavam toda a
dor
eu e mais uma vez Eu consegui Mas o
médico ele veio novamente e chegou para
minha mãe e falou assim mãezinha a sua
filha muito forte
já tomou regrediu você vai poder voltar
para casa vai poder levar ela para casa
e acabou
e eu fiquei imensamente feliz Voltei
para os meus amiguinhos eu tinha feito
novos amigos me despedir de outros a
morte ela era constante ela era uma
visita às vezes ela vinha para acalentar
Ah e não sabíamos disso e eu muito feliz
fiz a minha última cirurgia
o e fui para minha última conversa com o
médico
eu cheguei para ele toda feliz eu estava
com a minha calça jeans de novo voltando
para casa
aí ele virou para mim falou a Jéssica
você vai viver muito
É mas você não vai ter filho você não
pode ter filho
O que é a minha última sentença e eu
voltei para casa me sentindo uma artista
porque eu vou ter de avião minha família
inteira no aeroporto esperando naquele
dia Nós nos reunimos e fizemos uma
grande oração agradecemos a Deus por
tudo tudo tudo
o e os anos ele se passaram
e tudo foi ficando cada vez melhor
e em alguns anos depois eu percebi que
tudo isso pelo qual eu passei todos
esses amiguinhos Ana Júlia João Marcos
Lara
o João Pedro todos eles fizeram parte da
minha vida eu faço parte da vida deles
eles fazem parte da minha vida e aquela
cicatriz imensa que tinha ficado eu
construir um jardim
e o jardim lindo e cada um deles estão
comigo hoje
e aqui está
o João Marcos Ana Júlia
o Pedro Lara todos eles estão aqui
comigo eles são as flores do meu jardim
e as borboletas representam os nossos
voos e bem no centro
e está flor de lótus que sou eu porque
ela cresce e-mail pior terreno no pior
ambiente ela floresce linda e forte
se lembra daquela certeza que o médico
deu
se lembram da última sentença ele estava
certo
e eu não tive um filho eu tive dois
Italo e Daniela e são eles que hoje
colorem a minha vida e eu ensino eles a
colorir a vida deles
a todos os dias e essa mensagem que eu
quero deixar para vocês aqui hoje não
importa o quão cinza esteja o com escuro
a vida pareça pega seu pincel e com
loira
e sempre tem um lado bom transforme o
seu agora o poder estar com você
é muito obrigada meu nome é isso que eu
sabe onde e na certeza da morte eu
escolhi a vida né